hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're
gonna talk about the real cause of prostate
enlargement there is a lot of false information
floating around out there that states that this
condition is coming from too much DHT which is a
very powerful form of testosterone now if that was
true then why is it that this hormone is given to
men with enlarged prostates to shrink it it's used
as a therapy so that can't be the real cause in
fact as you age especially when you hit 50 this
hormone and this hormone decreases so how could
it be that all of a sudden at 50-year prostate
starts enlarging because the true cause of
a prostate enlargement is the combination
of ratio of low testosterone in high estrogen
because in a male body what does increase when
they when they get into the 40s and 50s and
60s is estrogen that's really what's causing
an enlarged prostate one of the big causes of
increased estrogen is not only the hormones in
the food supply but it's also drinking alcohol
so alcohol is notorious for increasing estrogen
in the body giving male about his breast tissue
you lose your hair on the the calves your voice
starts going high here but the prostate starts
enlarging okay so the couple of things you can
do to undo this and reverse this number one you
can not drink alcohol number one okay that's a
good idea number two you can start consuming
more cruciferous vegetables especially other
vegetables like beets would be good beet tops
would be good if you mix it with kale put it
in a blender with maybe a little bit of a cup
of frozen berries and blend it with water that
would be very good but the other two herbs that
I always recommend you can pretty much get them
anywhere is nettle root and saw palmetto nettle root is awesome for helping lower estrogen and
increasing testosterone and it's also good for
inflammation anywhere in the body it works like
that and then also adding this one as well it's
a great combination to help help you so go ahead
and try this and put your comments below I hope
this helps hey guys thank you so much for watching
I really appreciate it please click the share
button below and I will see you in the next video